THE WORLD'S LARGEST IPHONE
FACTORY IN CHINA PROTESTS.
>> THESE WORKERS, THEY'VE BEEN
ANGRY ABOUT WAGES.
THEY'RE ANGRY ABOUT DIRTY LIVING
CONDITIONS AND QUADS OF RIOT
POLICE ROLLED AND ONE GROUP IS
BEATING WORKERS WITH BATONS.
AND ANOTHER VIDEO SHOWS THEM
TEARING DOWN THE BARRIERS AND
THROWING THEM TOWARDS POLICE.
AND A GROUP OF WORKERS ARE
WORKING TOGETHER TO PUSH OVER A
POLICE CAR.
THAT YOUR CHEERING AND CHANTING
AS THEY PUSH THE CAR OVER.
AND THEY ARE TRYING TO CALM
THINGS DOWN.
THEY ARE OFFERING TO PAY THEM
THE EQUIVALENT OF $1,400 U.S.
DOLLARS TO QUICK AND LEAVE THE
FACTORY.
THAT PUTS EVEN MORE PRESSURE ON
APPLE.
THEY NEED THOSE WORKERS AHEAD OF
THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
THEY'VE ANNOUNCED THAT THE COVID
LOCKDOWNS IN CHINA ARE IMPACTING
SHIPMENTS AND MAKING THEM MORE
DELAYED.
THIS IS WHERE IT'S ESTIMATED
MORE THAN HALF OF THE WORLD'S
iPHONES ARE PRODUCED.
>> APPLE IS QUITE RELIANT ON
THAT FACTORY.
I KNOW YOU SPOKE TO AN EMPLOYEE
AT THE PROTEST.
I WONDER WHAT THEY TOLD YOU.
>> FOXCON IS THE MOST CRITICAL
SUPPLIER FOR APPLE.
THIS WORKER TOLD US THAT SCENES
AT THE PROTEST TURNED INTO A
RIVER OF BLOOD WITH POLICE
RUTHLESSLY HITTING WORKERS.
HE ALSO EXPLAINED THE PAYMENT
ISSUE HERE.
WEEKS AGO THERE WAS A MASS
EXODUS OF WORKERS FROM THE
FOXXCONOUT BREAK.
PEOPLE LITERALLY WATCHED MILES
TO TRY AND TRACT MORE PEOPLE,
PROMISING HIGHER PAY, BETTER
BONUSES.
BUT THE WORKER SAID WHEN THE NEW
WORKERS GOT TO THE PLANT, THE
PAY PLAN WAS MUCH WORSE THAN
ADVERTISED AND THEY FELT
CHEATED.
THEY ARE BLAMING THE PAYMENT
ISSUE ON A, QUOTE, TECHNICAL
ERROR.
POPPY, THIS IS AN UNUSUAL RARE
PUBLIC DISPLAY OF DISSENT BUT WE
HAVE SEEN MORE VIOLENT CLASHES
BREAK OUT DURING THECY CITIES,
STILL IN THE THIRD YEAR OF THE
PAN DEM UK.
>> SELENA, THANKS FOR FOLLOWING
THIS FOR US.